you reach reach how's a good names you
hey youtubers it's Charlie and it's time
for my Game of Thrones Season 4 preview
for Theon or reek I hope you're not
squeamish because this is going to get a
little bit messy sorry buddy yeah
hopefully you guys are seeing this in
the middle of the day because I'm in the
middle of a trip to New York so I'll try
and post it as soon as possible spoilers
for everything from seasons one two
three and mild spoilers for book five
though season three kind of changes a
lot of Theon story technically he was
not in the story from book three to book
four you really see him again in book
five once his point of view chapters
start happening but DB Weiss and David
Benioff didn't want to kick the actor
that was playing fee on off the show so
they wanted to include him so all the
scenes that we see for Theon in season
three technically happened off-camera in
the books when we do finally get fee on
POV chapters he's already become the
reek character and he's just remembering
all the things that happened to him all
the wounds and the body parts that got
chopped off the theme does a bit of
traveling in book five although a lot of
it doesn't happen till the end of that
book so I don't want to spoil too much
but he does make it out of that dungeon
at a certain point once he's become the
reek character I don't think that'll
happen in the first couple of episodes
in season four I do think he'll stay in
that dungeon for a little while longer
but if you remember the way they changed
Peter Dinklage's appearance after the
Battle of Blackwater Bay that character
the tyrion character was actually
severely disfigured but because they
didn't want to completely use
prosthetics they really kind of toned
down the disfigurement so I think
they're gonna do the same thing with
Theon because in the books he's actually
aged quite a bit he almost looks like an
old man after he comes this reek
character just because there's been so
much torture going on let me know you
think though are they going to do the
same thing they did with Peter Dinklage
in the tyrion character are they just
going to make him look really disfigured
like when Jamie did after he got his
hand chopped off by the brave companions
just to tie it more to Jamie after he
got his hand chopped off to if you
remember how he kind of got dragged
through the mud a lot and it was just
basically caked in filth that's kind of
what's going to happen to Theon's
character he's basically just gets
dragged through the mud for almost an
entire season and that she's going to
continue in season four
although there are some really important
changes you know how they're folding a
lot of story from before and the end of
book three into season four I think
they're gonna do the same thing with
fianc character but I think they're
gonna fold in some of the book 5 as well
if you remember at the end of season 3
Theon's sister actually made a pledge to
go get him eventually she ends up
getting captured by Stannis in the books
I think they're going to accelerate that
and if you remember I just did a video
on Stannis and his journey to the wall
you can actually watch that video after
you're done with this
but eventually Theon actually ends up
with Stannis as well so I think that
they're just going to converge a lot of
those storylines so that by the end of
season 4 Theon is with Stannis's army
now a lot of that actually happens in
Dance with Dragons book 5 so you can let
me know if you think that they're
actually going to go that far ahead
they're gonna be changing a lot of
things from seasons 4 5 & 6 just because
the books won't be done in time so even
if there's a winds of winter storyline
or even a dream of spring it might not
make it into Game of Thrones season
unless george RR martin tells them
what's going to happen to the characters
ahead of time let me know you thought
about a lot of let me know what you
thought about Theon in season 3 because
that's basically gonna continue in
season 4 did you think it was good for
them to show the torture scenes I don't
know sometimes I feel like it's better
to not show those things just because
your imagination makes that leap and
it's so much worse and they really just
want you to see the horror of what's
happening to Theon as the character kind
of progresses into this reek character
or transforms or devolves or whatever
you want to call it but after that
transformation is complete basically the
other characters who previously knew
Theon don't recognize them in the books
he runs into his sister and she doesn't
even recognize him just because he's so
disfigured there is a big wedding
subplot I know weddings are really big
on Game of Thrones but Ramsay snow has
this wedding with fake Arya and I don't
know if they're going to include that
because they haven't really included
that in the books yet but remember Arya
and Sansa have basically left King's
Landing but not everyone knows that the
Lannisters basically pass off a girl as
Arya Stark but it's someone that Theon
knows so there's this whole subplot but
they might not necessarily include that
in season 4 just because all the
supporting characters beyond being a
supporting character not a main
character don't necessarily get a lot of
major scenes isn't it funny how there
are so many weddings on a game of
Thrones and they're all terrible
another big part of fianc character
development in season 4 will be his
subtle brainwashing so the character
actually almost forgets his own name at
a certain point he pretty much forgets
it cuz he doesn't really say it out loud
he only says the reek name that really
creepy rhyme II says in the books reek
it rhymes with creep or reek it rhymes
with meek I don't know if he'll be
saying that out loud on this season but
they might allude to it because they do
like to include references to things
even if the characters don't say things
out loud
but let me know what you think is going
to happen to the Theon character are all
these things going to happen is he going
to become full-on reek in season 4
remember because it's a TV show they
like to keep the characters easy to
identify so they're not gonna disfigure
him too much but you can let me know you
think obviously Jaime and Brienne really
kind of got dragged through the mud but
you could really clearly tell it was
them it's not like they got all their
teeth knocked out or a tear and got his
nose chopped off like you did in the
books my next season for preview will be
for varies be sure to subscribe to get
that I'll try and post that video on
Monday like I said I'm in the middle of
some travel to New York so I'm trying to
get as many videos that as possible
tomorrow is actually legend of korra
episode 4 so get excited about that I'm
also posting my Sherlock giveaway
winners you can click here to get that
video and you can click here to get all
my other Game of Thrones Season 4 videos
thank you so much for watching you guys
are awesome
high fives
you